we do have a great show tonight so just
think so Andy absolutely and we have a
great crowd - to be fair to be fair we
don't really know yet I mean they seem
good but we we don't know for sure I
know I'm just curious what are you what
are you basing this on we've only been
with this crowd for a couple of minutes
you really don't trust me do you
Coenen I said they're a great crowd
because I know they are how do I know
watch this each day I try to make sure
we have a great crowd for that night
show with a rigorous screening process
now preggos out it's important because
if we don't have a great audience
Coenen scolds them and forces them to
lead then he retreats to his underground
bunker of sadness for exactly 24 hours
at the testing facility I start off with
basic health tests I obtain vitals from
each audience member to make sure
they're healthy enough to endure 15
minutes of entertainment over a period
of 30 minutes mr. a one-eared question
written intelligence test as well as
visual intelligence tests okay is this a
banana or an apple good humor
comprehension quizzes excellent eater
seat usage tests no honey honey put your
bottom on there you go okay and applause
clap strength testing laugh analysis
very nice very nice
I look at everyone's nude photo ah very
nice loop very nice that is how I know
they're a great crowd
[Applause]